I'm David. I run R
for the rest of us.
And I'm here to talk
to you about starting
a business with the R.
But here's the thing.
I never actually intended
to start my own business
and to show you how
unintentional my path to doing
what I do now has been.
Let me give you a brief story.
In 2015, I was working
my last 9 to 5 job.
My wife had just started
a job at the time.
It was a pretty challenging job,
but she likes challenging jobs.
At the time we were
hoping to have kids,
so we were overjoyed
when we found out
that she was pregnant
with not one but two kids,
we were going to have twins.
Now, at the time we
talked about what to do.
I really like kids.
I used to be an
elementary school teacher,
so we decided that I would
stay home with our kids
and she would continue working.
Now, for those of
you who have kids,
you might not be surprised
to hear that my pre-kid
vision of what being a full time
stay at home dad would be like
was pretty different from
the post-kid reality.
And so after a few months, my
wife very kindly said to me,
you know, it's OK if this
isn't going to quite work out
the way we imagined it might.
What happened, though,
at the same time
was that the challenging
job that my wife
Rachel had started actually
came to feel untenable.
Having young kids and an
incredibly challenging job
was just a bit too much, and
she ended up leaving that job.
So in a few months we had gone
from having two jobs and 0 kids
to having 0
jobs and two kids.
And it was at that
time I realized, OK, I
need to do something to bring in
a little income for our family.
So I started doing some
freelance data analysis work.
I was an Excel user at the time.
I used Excel for everything,
but I got a little bit bored
and I had heard
about R and I had
heard that R could do some
nice stuff, automate things,
make nice dataviz.
And I was like, OK,
cool, let me learn that.
I taught myself R
and in the process
realized, first of all,
that I really liked it.
And second of all, that there
were a lot of people like me
who also wanted to learn
R and so it was from that
experience that I started
R for the Rest of Us. Today,
R for the Rest of Us
does both education work,
We have online courses,
trainings for organizations,
as well as consulting work.
And I'm going to use
examples from our business,
but this isn't really ultimately
a talk about my business.
This is a talk
about your business.
I'm going to focus
mostly on marketing,
on how to sell your work.
And the reason why
is it's a thing
that people who are
thinking about starting
their own business
ask me the most.
They say, "David, I want
to start my own business,
"but I have no idea
how to find clients.
How did you do it?"
And I know there are some
people potentially in the room.
Maybe you're waiting for the
next talk who are thinking,
"You know what, I
don't actually want
to start my own business,"
before you run for the doors.
I think the reason you
might consider staying
is that marketing matters,
even if you're just working.
Even if you are working
for someone else.
So you need to, for
example, sell your own work
within your own organization
so your boss or your coworkers
see what you're capable of.
Maybe you're making an
R package and you want
to get it out into the world.
You need to market it.
So rather than put
our heads in the sand
and not do any marketing, let's
learn how to do marketing well.
A quick question.
If you would say that you like
marketing, would you
go ahead and raise your hand?
So I see a handful,
maybe like 10 max.
Not that many people in the
room, I would say, overall
say they enjoy marketing.
And I think the
reason why is this.
Technical people
like us tend to be
pretty allergic to marketing.
And I know that because I in the
past very much felt like this.
We think, OK, if I write
really good code, that
should be enough.
I shouldn't have to
go out and sell it.
Right? What I've
realized is that
another thing I've come to
realize in the last few years
is that when people say that
they don't like marketing,
the marketing that
they're thinking of
is often kind of
like this, right?
Like think about stuff
you've seen on social media
with a ton of hashtags linked to
who knows where trying to sell
who knows what, right?
Like that type of
sleazy marketing.
But what I've come to realize
in running R for the Rest of Us
is that marketing can
actually look more
like this, can look
like education,
it can look like teaching.
And so I think when
you do marketing well,
it doesn't actually
even necessarily
seem like marketing.
Let me give some examples
from other people who
run kind of consulting
businesses of how they talk
about marketing and ways
that their approach also
shows up in what we do
with R for the Rest of Us.
So Paul Minors was asked
how he does marketing,
how he finds his clients.
He's a consultant who trains
on Asana and Pipedrive.
The details don't really
matter, but what he said
is, "The way I do
marketing is simple.
"I go to where my
ideal clients are.
And I'm hopeful."
And so with R for the Rest
of Us, what that's meant
is we go to where people
are, which, probably
won't be a huge
surprise for folks
here, is Twitter.
That's where the R
community tends to show up.
And the way we're
helpful is every day
For the last 3 and
1/2 years, we have
tweeted out one tip
every day at 7:30 AM.
Sometimes things that we
create, oftentimes things
that other people create.
And so through doing that.
We've been
able to build up
a following of over
15,000 followers, which
becomes useful in ways
I'll talk about shortly.
Wes Bos talks about
his approach being this.
"Share your knowledge for free
with no strings attached."
On the R for the
Rest of Us website
we have a blog.
There are a bunch of posts.
This is an example of one
on how to set up Git and GitHub
if you're working with
R, and I wrote it first
of all because it was
something I struggled with.
So I figured other people
probably would as well.
People can go on the
R for the Rest of Us
website, can read this for free.
They don't have to
pay us anything.
And I'm totally fine with that.
I want to give that value.
And the thing with
offering things for free
is that, this is taken
from Adam Wathan, who
says that "Giving away
your work for free
"is like compressing a spring.
"And that spring releases
when you finally
have something up for sale."
So rather than thinking
about marketing is going out
and saying, "Hey, I'm selling
this, I'm selling that."
It's much better if you
can go out and offer value,
offer things for free, and
once you get that goodwill,
hopefully get some
following as well,
then you can offer
things that are paid.
So this is an email that
I send out twice a year
announcing the start
of a program called
R in 3 months, where we do
a training thing, a three month
training program for folks.
And when I send that out,
because we've built up
that goodwill, because we've
offered things for free,
people are more
interested in signing up.
I'm going to now offer
kind of four lessons that
have been really useful
for me in thinking
about how to find clients.
So if we think about OK
marketing done well generally
looks kind of like education.
What are some more specific ways
that we can look for clients?
So the first lesson
that I'm going to offer
is to think about going deep,
not broad.
So people will sometimes
say to me, "Hey,
"I really like what you're doing.
"You know, I
like teaching, too.
"Like, I'd love to start
a business training
people to learn R."
and they'll say--and
I'll ask, "OK great.
"Like, who are you thinking about
trying to work with?" and they say,
"Well, anybody."
But here's the problem if
you try to speak to everyone.
No one will listen.
Your message is just too
general and people don't--it's
not going to resonate
if it's overly general.
So instead, what you
really want to do
is find your people.
In business speak,
people will talk about
niching down, finding
a niche that you can work in.
And so with R for
the Rest of Us, even
the name of the business is
that was like my first attempt
to kind of niche down.
I'm not necessarily
trying to train everybody.
I'm training the rest of us.
Now, of course,
everybody interprets that
slightly differently.
But generally speaking, what I
think of as our ideal audience
is people who want to learn
R but are intimidated by it.
And I pitch everything to
that specific audience.
On marketing emails that go out,
in the footer of those emails,
This is what the text says.
Think you know what
an R user looks like?
I'm probably not what
you have in mind.
I'm not a hardcore quant.
I won't jump on you
for any small mistake
and I want to help
others avoid the pain.
And you can see
through this language
I am trying to identify
this is the type of person
that I think R for the
Rest of Us is best for.
It's not that other
people couldn't--like any,
I think anybody can learn
R through the materials
that we offer.
But this is really like
our ideal audience.
And so for some people
that's not going to resonate
and that's OK.
But for other people
that really will resonate
and they'll be inclined to
work to learn R through us.
Whereas a more general
framing probably
wouldn't appeal to them.
In addition to turning
people on, having language
that speaks to certain
people, it's really important
also to turn people off.
And I know that sounds
counterintuitive
because you think, well, you
want to have an offering that's
going to be like
applicable to anybody,
but it actually
doesn't work very well.
And turning people off is
a really effective strategy
to help you identify the niche
that you do want to work in.
So I'm in the process
of writing a book.
It's called R
without statistics,
which is my attempt to both
say what the book is, but also
what it's not.
It's, broadly speaking, a
book about quirky, interesting
things that you can
do with R that don't
involve any complex statistics.
So when I tweeted about this
in march, I got this feedback.
Luis wrote "Marketing tip.
"The label will
create a huge barrier
among statisticians
and scholars."
And I put this up not in
any way to disparage Luis.
Like, I really
appreciate the feedback,
but the thing is, that's
not my target audience.
Statisticians and scholars
I mean, maybe they'll
read the book.
I'm more than happy for
them to read the book,
but that's not the audience
that I'm going for.
And by calling it
R without statistics,
I'm intentionally trying to
turn some people on, but also
turn some people off.
Lesson 2: focus on results.
So it's really easy
for those of us
who are technical to get really
into the tools that we use.
You know, we want to talk
about this new package
or this new function
that I learn.
For clients, though, what
they really care about
is getting to the goal.
As an example of this.
A couple, two or
three years ago,
a potential client came to us
from the state of Connecticut
and they said, David, we
have to produce 169 reports,
one for each town in the
state of Connecticut.
We use Excel.
We have no idea how
this is going to work.
I've heard that R can
maybe do this. In my head
what I'm thinking
is, "Yeah, of course,
"like R Markdown,
parameterized reporting,
and pagedown package,"
but that's not at all
what I'm going to say to them.
Instead, I'm going to
frame it as, yeah, we
can help you to automate this,
we can do it more efficiently,
and we'll also do it in a
way that there will be fewer
copy paste errors.
They care about that end result.
They don't care about the tools
generally that we're using.
So we did that report and
this is what we ended up
producing entirely
with the tools
that I talked about. On
the R for the Rest of Us
website on the consulting
page, the headline
is "Communicate More
Effectively and Efficiently."
Note that I'm not talking
about any R packages, anything
like that.
I'm talking about how to
communicate effectively
and efficiently,
which is language
that I think will
resonate with my clients
and potential clients.
Lesson 3 is to make
your client the hero.
It's really easy when you're
developing marketing materials
early on to say, I can
do this, I can do that.
But really, the way you
want to position yourself
is as the guide that
is helping your client.
But the client remains
the hero of the story.
So this is a report we
did in 2020, maybe 2021
on census outreach efforts
in the 2020 census.
And when I write about
this, I have a case study
on the R for the
Rest of Us website.
Here's what I say.
The 52 reports helped ORS
Impact and the Democracy
Funders Network, that was
our client, to achieve
their goals and more.
And they did this without
the agonizing manual work.
So I'm talking about--
I'm framing it in a way
that I think will resonate
with potential new clients.
And I'm framing the
client here as the hero,
not saying, you
know, we did this.
I'm saying we
helped them to make
these reports without that
agonizing manual work.
Last lesson is this:
relationships matter
more than technical skills.
When you're starting out, it's
really easy to think, you know,
I just got to tweak this one
bit of CSS on my website.
To be honest, that
doesn't really
matter that much when
you first start out
because your first clients
are almost certainly going
to come from people you know.
At the same time that
you cultivate existing
relationships, it's important
to cultivate new relationships.
So for me, what this
often looks like is
I'll see people tweet
about R for the Rest of Us.
And I'm really
grateful when they do.
Of course, it's like
fantastic marketing for me,
so I'll follow up
with them and I'll
say thank you for doing that.
I really appreciate that.
And I'll do something like
give them a free course.
And so by doing that, you
know, I make, hopefully,
cultivate a good relationship.
But then also maybe this person
signs up for another course
or R in 3 Months or
mentions it to a colleague.
I think it can lead to
other things in the future.
So to wrap up, I want to
leave you with this idea.
You are not me.
I've given examples
here and I've
drawn lessons from the work
of R for the Rest of Us.
But it's really important
to focus not so much
on the specific tactics
that we've used, rather
focusing on the larger lessons.
As an example, if
you were thinking
about becoming a consultant,
working with data science
teams, you'd probably talk
more about the technical side
of things than we tend to.
But you still want to
do it in a way that
frames the conversation
around the end result,
as opposed to an overemphasis on
the technical tools themselves.
So I hope I have left
you with the idea
that it is possible to sell your
work without selling your soul.